6 26
on friday morning making progress in the
middle of the night
at the 95 in the northern 215 beltway
you got it we're going
centennial bowling so we did have a
recent centennial bowl story we
mentioned an
overnight concrete pour
the nevada department of
transportation's tony illia provided
these
excellent photos of how that went down
thanks to the project manager and the
crews who coordinated just this
one complicated part of the overall
project
the john herbert bridge will help
connect centennial parkway north of the
beltway
under the flyover from the west 215 to
the south 95
over the beltway itself to tropical
parkway on the south side
via an extension of sky point
it's a lot to take in tony tells me that
john herbert died in 2016 at the age of
83
he was an honorably discharged army vet
who relocated to southern nevada in 2005
and volunteered as a crossing guard
helping kids safely cross streets so the
online version of this you can
review all that complicated stuff and
all of our stories are on 8newsnow.com
just click traffic then driving you
crazy buckle up drive carefully please
put down that phone
if there is something driving you crazy
email me traffic 8 8newsnow.com